hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round five of
the 2021 video world cup
it's vasiv durabili of azerbaijan versus
vidit and it's uh
one of those games that features uh a
piece that's
kinda kinda useless also you know
sometimes a piece can be a great piece
but sometimes you know it can be
worse than a pawn and this is one such
game it's a very very
sad piece uh could also be characterized
as a miserable piece you'll see what i
mean by this and it's a it's a really
uh wait so it's a beautiful game so
without further ado let's check it out
and see why so many of you suggested it
so
uh the rabbi with the white pieces opens
with e4 we have e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to
b5 now
yeah going for the real lopes we have a6
bishop to a4 and now
knight to f6 so the columbus variation
of the morphe's defense
we have castles and now b5 with bishop
to b3
and now bishop to c5 so a very popular
line nowadays uh we have a4 attacking
the flank uh
and now rook to b8 and there are many
popular moves here for white c3 is the
most popular you could also capture here
but there is also one very cool move and
that is knight captures on e5 so a
temporary piece sacrifice
but as you can imagine when the knight
captures uh on e5 we're gonna play d4
and
attack the bishop and the knight so here
we have knight captures and
d4 and now black wins the pawn back by
bishop captures and e4 we have queen
captures
now attacking the knight here and d6
simply defending the knight
uh we have bishop to f4 f4 is also very
popular here uh here dorado reilly goes
for bishop to f4
and now c5 getting a lot of expansion
here
we have queen to e3 and now c4
so attacking the bishop here we have
bishop to a2
and now uh there's there are a couple of
games that reach this position the most
notable but a notable one being a
swiddler versus
arun from the this year's grand chester
in paris
they played the blitz game uh where uh
arunyan defeated
uh svidler and he castled here basically
all of the games that reach this
position featured castles here
but instead of castles the video goes
for knight to h5 and it is only now as
of move 13 that we have a completely new
game
so basically he's asking do you want to
trade the bishop here or do you want to
trade the bishop like this uh
for me to capture it uh here we have
knight to c3 continuing development and
now
knight captures on f4 queen captures and
divided the just
castles uh we have a character some b5 a
captures on b5 and now
well the question is how do you get this
bishop into the game it's going to be
very hard because well
this uh structure here is not going to
move so basically what you could do is
maybe move the rook play bishop b1
move the knight somewhere and then play
c3 and then the bishop will be staring
at this e4 pawn for who knows
how long so that's maybe one of the uh
possible scenarios but here we have rook
8 to d1 uh bishop to e6 by vetted and
now
bishop back to b1 uh and here it has a
really really awesome plan
and he starts executing it with b4 so he
attacks the knight here
says do you want to go to d5 or do you
want to go back to e2 and the problem is
if
knight to d5 we can just trade because
white already has one piece that he can
never use so why not uh
you know trade as many pieces as we can
and then you know imagine if we trade
everything off and we're left with one
piece
uh this beautiful knight on e5 and the
white is stuck with
this bishop it's like we're up a piece
so definitely makes sense
so instead after this b4 movie of
knights the e2 dora bailey wants to
keep all of his uh well useful pieces on
the board
and now queen to b6 uh so what do you
play here
uh the problem is you can't really
unwind with c3 i mean you could play it
but for example captures captures and
now
uh what do you play here uh let's say
bishop g4 by black and uh it's a really
really bad position for white it's uh
very very hard to play this not a lot of
active moves for white
so instead we have h3 taking away the g4
square from with it and now comes
c3 and this is such a beautiful move uh
because it
basically forces white to choose between
two options that are just bad
so here uh best for white is to just
play b3
but who does this if you're a human you
do not play this and
you know create this tomb for a light
square bishop
no one plays this uh so instead after c3
we have b
captures in c3 but now comes a move that
it had in mind a very nice solution to
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find
this idea think very carefully while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding the move
but not just
finding the move but rather calculating
it all the way because it's not the same
thing
as and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop the c4 here
virus bishop is just showing off
how it's a really really awesome piece
how it's very active you know everyone
um
is just applauding this bishop for for a
job well done
where is this bishop uh well you you you
get where i'm going
so the knight is attacked and what are
you going to play you can't move the
knight otherwise you lose the rook on f1
so rook
f the e1 defending the knight and now we
simply remove the defender of the c3
pawn bishop captures
rook captures and now b captures on c3
and now comes the punch line
uh here the bishop can move it cannot
move if the bishop goes to a2 then queen
a6
wins the game as white will lose a piece
you attack the the bishop and the rook
here
so here we have rook back to e1 white
hoping to get this bishop to a2 move in
but vidiq just plays a rook to a8 and he
says nope that bishop is staying there
on b1
so queen to g3 attacking the c3 pawn now
just
rook to c8 and now how can white
continue this it's not a very not a very
active position
and you know black's plan is just to
bring the knight to c4 and then to d2
and then white will have a useless
bishop and
two useless rooks so that that's that's
pretty terrible so here we have king the
h2
trying to get this f4 moving to kick
away uh this knight and maybe start with
some f5 f6 ideas maybe we can check made
the black king
but now rook to a3 adding another
defender here of course
black knows that white will do some rook
lifting here
and it's a very useful move as you'll
see because now we have rook to e3
and uh the the point is if you play uh
uh
well not not a very useful move here
we're just gonna kick away the knight
and then
the knight cannot come to c4 because
rook captures here uh this will no
longer be defended so instead after rook
to e3 visited to just place queen to b4
adds another defender to the c3 pawn now
knight to c4 to d2 is definitely
happening
and also the queen just defends uh the
spawn so that's
also very nice uh unfortunately you
can't do a nice rook to d5 rook lift
because then the bishop hangs
so there's also that so here we have f4
but now
knight to c4 now we can play it the rook
here is under attack
uh and you don't really gain anything by
moving the rook like i said the knight
is coming to d2 it's just a terrible
position for white
so white instead goes queen g4 as the
rook here is
not defended but now rook to b8
we rook to g3 now threatening checkmate
now g6 and here we have f5 by doorbelly
not trying to bust open the position a
little bit but it's going to be very
hard you don't have
if the light square bishop could help
with the attack it'd be great but
yeah so here vidic goes knight to d2 and
now already
that's uh that's a really bad bishop
that that rook isn't really doing
anything the queen
and rook here are really bad uh but not
not just that you're just
threatening to win the game by by
winning this piece so here
uh capturing doesn't really do anything
like we said
there's no way to continue the attack so
here we have queen to f4
now trying to uh trying to maybe
uh stir some trouble here because maybe
if let's say
well there's nothing that you can do if
knight captures on e4 maybe we can do
that
uh then maybe you can play something
like rook g to d3 and then gain some
activity but david of course not
interested in
ruining his setup his knight is just
beautiful there
he just plays queen to d3 a very nice
centralizing move and now white has to
be
really careful uh because uh well the
queen is now eyeing that rook and maybe
if the knight moves uh you know delivers
a check we could maybe win some material
here
uh but you can't do it right away a rook
to d3 here
is uh kind of a possibility but then we
just play queen e5 we trade the queens
and white cannot afford to trade any
active pieces because most of his pieces
are bad and if you trade off active
pieces you're left with nothing to play
with there's this rook and that's it
that's all white has
so instead after queen d4 we have f
captures on g6 okay but it captures back
h captures on g6 and now rook to g5 um
and now well what do you play here i
know a lot of you guys want to play
knight to f3 check and pick up this rook
but you can't
queen captures and f3 defends the rook
so you know don't do that
so after rook to g5 we have rook to a1
you could also just go uh and grab a
piece here but with it
likes to prepare it properly so he just
goes rook to a1 adds another attacker
and there's nothing white can do we have
rook to d5 here
but just queen captures an e4 there
there's no no playing this
queen captures on d6 now attacking the
rook here but now just to rook a
captures on b1 also defends the rook
here and
that's it there's nothing more white can
play
a few moves more were played rook to d4
now queen to e6 offering uh a queen
trade
we have queen to c7 but now comes queen
to b6 by verit and he was in this
position on move 38
that avasiv durabili uh resigned the
game and as the first game ended in the
draw and vidiq won the second game
this means that vedic is the second
player to enter the quarterfinals
alongside
sam shankland and the other six players
will have to go into tie breaks tomorrow
to decide uh you know matters between
them so congratulations to vidit on such
a spectacular
game uh really you know just destroying
that light square bishop
uh and here okay you resign uh your down
material and there's nothing you can do
you if you trade queens we're just going
to play rook captures on b6 and if real
characters real capture so i mean
we're up a night here it's not really
not really uh
something you can play uh but what was
uh the most
fascinating i think about this game is
that um
uh how how quickly it happened you know
from this moment where we said that uh
um
arunyan played against zwiller this
castle's move uh vidit
had this uh all of this planned so
eliminate
a white stark square bishop and just
leave him with this
terrible terrible light square bishop
which is which is so sad
uh because the light square bishop in
the real lopez is such a powerful piece
you know
yeah you know if you remember
all the bobby fischer games that we've
covered what uh you know
how how powerful of a piece the light
square bishop in the rural opus can be
you know people
develop it to b5 sometimes they bring it
all the way to a4 to b3 sometimes they
shift it all the way back to f1 and then
you know use it
later on to uh you know do great things
but here
uh you know it is just amazing i i i
think we could agree
uh that this uh definitely was the the
worst
bishop ever uh you know there are
many more bad bishops but you know it's
a really really a high-rated game so i
think between two
such high rated gentlemen that this
bishop is um well well the worst i i
could be wrong but you know
tell me your thoughts and maybe you have
a game that you you
figure that has uh has the worst bishop
uh so
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank mika kennedy
uh michael colbert
tom deralo uh michael j woodriding and
the daniel hall back for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the video world cup checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world we're
going to be covering the tie breaks
tomorrow
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day